the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Theory video today I
will be talking about her old friends
Varys and Tyrion Lannister these are a
couple characters that have been around
ever since the very first season of this
amazing show
they weren't extremely close at the
beginning of the story but over the
years I think it's safe to say these two
characters have grown on each other and
even us as the audience their
relationship became much closer after
Varys did help Tyrion escape from King's
Landing ever since then you can usually
find both of these characters in the
same scenes with each other we can even
see Tyrion and Varys with each other in
the new trailer now that we are heading
into the final season everyone wants to
know what will happen to all of the
characters now the interesting thing
about Tyrion and Varys is they typically
do more counselling than they do
fighting now we did see Tyrion Lannister
fighting during the Battle of Blackwater
Bay but we have never seen Varys fight
in one of the battles it doesn't look
like he will be doing much fighting in
the final season either we could see
Varys hiding down below Winterfell in
the season 8 trailer so the question is
what can we expect to see from these
characters what can they have véra
centurion dude that would give their
characters an interesting or exciting
ending well I think I may know how both
of their stories end but you might not
like it last year I made some videos
where I talked about some potential
outcomes for Tyrion and Varys in those
videos I said I believe one of them may
betray Daenerys Targaryen since then I
have continued to think about this and I
am now wondering if Tyrion and Varys
could betray Daenerys together now I
know that might sound crazy right now
because both of them are two of Danny's
most closest advisers but let's just
take a look at some of the evidence I
believe the writing has already on the
wall for both of these characters to
betray Dany it seems like they have been
foreshadowing this ever since season 6
but it starts to become very obvious in
my opinion once you re-watch season 7
now it may be a little harder for me to
show you why I think Tyrion will betray
Danny because of the clues for this have
been a little more subtle than it is for
Varys now it's no secret that Danny and
Tyrion were not seeing I died during
last season no pun intended that all
started when Tyrion was having to start
to strategize attacks against his own
family now we all know Tyrion and Cersei
do not like each other very much but
that doesn't mean Tyrion is ready to
have her killed
Daenerys even started to question this
herself
what Daenerys said to Tyrion on the
beach a dragon stone may have been a big
clue about his actual intentions now
before I start showing you any of the
video clips make sure you look very
closely at the ways Dany and Tyrion look
at each other in these scenes the
dialogue doesn't always tell the full
story
sometimes a character's expression can
say a lot to the blockade of King's
Landing we have a plan it's still the
right plan the right plan your strategy
has haces dawn the Iron Islands and the
weak if I have underestimated our
enemies enemies your family you mean
perhaps you don't want to hurt them
after all
so as you can see Daenerys is beginning
to question Tyrians loyalty Danny isn't
quite sure that Tyrion is actually ready
to defeat his own family which is
understandable
like I said Tyrion may not like Cersei
but he doesn't necessarily want to see
her or Jaime get killed in the process
and Danny taking the Iron Throne
if I were Daenerys I would be keeping a
close eye on Tyrion myself because as we
all know blood is always thicker than
water
now at the end of this episode when
Danny attacks the Lannister army you can
see all of this is starting to weigh on
Tyrion as he watches some of his own
former men get burned alive you have to
remember Terry and most likely fought
side by side with some of these men
during the Battle of Blackwater Bay it
wasn't too long ago when Tyrion was
having to count on these men for
survival so you can understand why we
can see the pain ontarians face not to
mention he was also worried that his
brother could get killed during that
attack now in the very next episode we
begin to see the foundation of their
relationship start to crack even more
this is when Danny decides to burn the
tarly's for not bending the knee this is
something that Tyrion does not agree
with but the decision has already been
made just take a look at the way Danny
and Tyrion are looking at each other in
those scenes if looks could kill one of
them would have been dead already I'm
not here to put men in Chains if that
becomes an option many will take it I
gave her a choice they made it Chris you
stop the heading entirely heading
anything
your grace
as you can see Danny antarians
relationship isn't working like it once
was they both have two very different
ways of approaching things
shortly after this is when we see tyrion
and varys having a conversation about
Danny you need to find a way to make
listen now what's interesting about this
is I don't think Tyrion will ever find a
way to make Daenerys listen next season
we will finally see Daenerys attack
King's Landing to take back the Iron
Throne the only problem is I also think
Daenerys will have no choice but to burn
the city
I don't think Tyrion wants to see that
happen but let's continue now let's take
a look at another scene from last season
this time t rain and Danny are talking
about succession he wants to know what
Danny's plans are for the future
how does she plan on keeping the wheel
broken after she dies but Danny doesn't
want to talk about this at all until she
actually takes the Iron Throne this
leads to another disagreement between
the two characters now take a look at
Tyrians face right as Danny leaves the
room like I said if looks could kill
Danny would have been dead at that
moment is this one of the items you
discussed with your brother in Kingsland
I'm trying to serve you by planning for
the long term perhaps if you plan for
the short term we wouldn't have lost
Dorne Highgarden we will discuss the
succession after I wear the crown
[Music]
as you can see they cannot agree on
anything but this isn't the only
disagreement in that episode later Danny
decides to go out beyond the wall to try
to save John and company Tyrion thought
this was too big of a risk
he knew that Danny could potentially die
therefore all the progress they have
made would have been for nothing but
Danny could not just sit by while the
other characters were in serious danger
then in the very next episode the season
7 finale I think we get even more
foreshadowing for a betrayal coming from
Tyrion it starts with the meeting at the
dragon pit as we all know Tyrion
volunteers to go inside to try to change
Circe's mind about helping them after
talking to Cersei for a few minutes he
notices Cersei doesn't drink any alcohol
so he comes to the conclusion that
Cersei has to be pregnant as soon as
Tyrion says that out loud the scene
comes to an end we have no idea what
happens next all we know is Cersei does
come outside to agree to help John and
Danny although we later find out that
she lied so the million-dollar question
is what else did Tyrion say to Cersei do
they now have some kind of a secret plan
we will find out next season then we get
one more scene after this which is the
infamous look Ontarians face as he
realizes John and Danny are having sex
together now there are a lot of
different reasons why Tyrion could have
had that look on his face but we won't
know for sure until next season after
taking a look at some of those scenes
again it does look like they are
foreshadowing something now let me show
you how this connects to Varys obviously
we get one of our biggest clues from
Melisandre during last season we saw a
conversation between Varys and
Melisandre when they were both at
Dragonstone together this was when Varys
told Melisandre she should not stay in
Westeros because it might not be safe
Melisandre told him she was leaving for
volantis but she would come back one
last time Melisandre said that she would
die in Westeros but she also said that
Varys would die too
I will return their Spyder one last time
m'lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you you could see that
this scared the [ __ ] out of eros he has
to be wondering why she would say that
does she know something he doesn't
maybe Varys already knows this as well
because as we all know Varys did hear a
voice from the flames when he was just a
child we actually heard about this story
when interestingly enough Varys told it
to Tyrion Lannister Vera stole Tyrion
some of the story about how he was cut
as a child he burned my parts in a
brazier the flames turned blue
and I heard a voice answer his call I
still dream of that night not of the
sorcerer not of his blade I dream of the
voice from the flames was it a god a
demon we have yet to find out what that
voice said but whatever it said
continues to haunt Varys till this day
Varys has hated magic ever since he also
does not like anyone that follows rule
or which we all know Melisandre and can
Vera do when Melisandre told Varys he
would die I think this actually scared
him because she basically confirmed
whatever he heard from the flames now
the question is how will Varys die it
doesn't look like he will die in battle
because we never see him fight also like
I said at the beginning of the video we
can see Varys hiding down in the crypts
of Winterfell so if Varys doesn't die in
battle then there must be another reason
which leads me to my next scene I think
we got one of our biggest clues from kin
Varro now what's also interesting about
this scene is who Varys was with when
kinvaras old him this that's right you
guessed it Varys was with none other
than Tyrion Lannister his new partner in
crime I believe can Vora tells us
exactly why Varys will die and it may
end up being the same reason why Tyrion
dies next season too
should I tell you what the voice said
should I tell you the name of the one
who spoke
[Music]
we serve the same queen
if you are her true friend you have
nothing to fear from me as you can see
can Vora questions varus's loyalty she
does this because she does not fully
trust him most likely because she has
already seen something in the flames as
well in fact we know she has seen
something because she says do you want
me to tell you what the voice said that
also scared the [ __ ] out of Eris because
he does not want to believe it but can
vara and Melisandre are basically
confirming it they were not there when
Varys was cut but they already know how
his story ends can vara told him we
serve the same queen as long as you are
her true friend you have nothing to fear
from me the only problem is Varys is not
our true friend well at least not for
long we know something will go wrong
because Melisandre has already told us
Varys will die now let's take a look at
another scene from last season once
again Daenerys has to question loyalty I
believe what Daenerys says do Varys is
also some foreshadowing about how their
stories will end Varys will end up
betraying Daenerys Targaryen next season
as will Tyrion Lannister
like I said Varys and Tyrion are always
together we see them together in most of
their scenes well as I said before I
believe the writing is already on the
wall if you ever think I'm failing the
people you won't conspire behind my back
you look me in the eye as you have done
today and you'll tell me how I'm failing
me I swear it my queen and I swear this
if you ever betray me
I'll burn you alive they have been
setting this up since season six but
even more so during last season there
are more than enough scenes to go back
and see where they laid the groundwork
for this betrayal
since Varys and Tyrion are always
together I believe they will do this
together
let me know what you think down below do
you think that is enough for shadowing
or am I looking too far into these
scenes anyways I want to thank everyone
for watching today's video
I also want to thank all of my patreon
supporters I hope everyone has a great
day I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]